et
depuis le sikorsky h 34 et surtout la
fabuleuse alouettes
les hélicoptères de l'armée de l'air ont
considérablement évolué et on peut dire
aujourd'hui qu'ils font partie
intégrante du dispositif de défense elle
rien de français l'émission que les
accomplissent tous les jours sont des
missions de sauvetage en mer ou à terre
au profit des pilotes ou des personnels
de l'armée mais aussi des civils ainsi
que des missions de récupération rumba
au sein même des territoires ennemis
la route est là
ils accomplissent aussi des missions de
sûreté aérienne qui se développe de plus
en plus dans le cadre de la lutte
antiterroriste
d'autres missions sont confiées aux
hélicoptères de la bella 107 de
villacoublay
il s'agit du transport des membres du
gouvernement ou de leurs invités
alors le fennec est la version bi moteur
et militarisé de l'écureuil appareils
remarquable de maniement dont le premier
vol remonte en 1974 le fennec qui son
premier vol en 1990 il est entré en
service dans l'armée de l'air
la même année d'une masse à vide de 1700
kg pour une masse au décollage de 2500
kg il est motorisé par deux turbines
turbomeca tm 321 arius d'une poussée de
400 chevaux chacune
long de 10 mètres 60 avec un diamètre de
rotor de 12 mètres 34 sa vitesse
maximale est de 225 km heure pour un
rayon d'action de 700 kilomètres sous un
plafond de 6500 m
selon la version le fennec peut être
équipé de plusieurs types d'armements en
particulier du canon automatique j'ai
hâte de 20 mm doté de 240 au but le
pointage en azimuts de larmes et en
assurer aux palonnier présents sur les
bases de villacoublay m istres toulouse
et bordeaux
le fennec peut avoir de couleur gris ou
camouflage traditionnels ce dernier
étant progressivement remplacé par le
gris opérationnel
les missions qui lui sont confiées sont
extrêmement variés des liaisons à la
reconnaissance en passant par le
sauvetage et la formation
ces images que nous voyons ont été
réalisés au cours d'un stage de
formation initiale de trop liste sur la
base aérienne 125 d'istres
depuis les inondations de nîmes les
fennecs 2 le h 05 67 alpine
interviennent dans ce contexte avec de
plus en plus souvent l'obligation
d'effectuer des treillages denis grâce
aux jumelles de vision nocturne
la présence à bord de sauveteurs
plongeurs qualifiés et entraîner est un
gage de sécurité pour les sinistrés
on
de retour de mission les appareils
rejoignent le hangar ultramoderne dont
est dotée aujourd'hui l'escadron
do mistral pour protéger une aire de
stationnement ces locaux allie
fonctionnalité modernité et esthétique
le puma dont le premier vol a eu lieu le
5 avril 1965 est entré en service en
1974 sa masse à vide et de 3615 kg pour
une masse au décollage de 7000 kg
équipé de deux turbines turbomeca turmo
trois c4 d'une puissance de 1400 chevaux
chacune il peut atteindre une vitesse
maximale de 275 km
longs de 18,1 m son rayon d'action et de
572 km avec une charge utile de 3200 kg
ou 18 passagers le puma est de plus en
plus remplacé par le super puma dans
l'ensemble de ses missions le super puma
a volé pour la première fois en 1978
pour une entrée en service en 1984
d'un encombrement sensiblement identique
aux pumas il affiche une masse au
décollage de 9 tonnes soit 5 tonnes de
plus que ce dernier
les turbines malika de turbomeca qui
l'équipe ont une poussée de 1600 chevaux
chacune et lui confère une vitesse
maximale de 280 km heure
l'émission des pumas est super puma sont
principalement des missions dites sar
search and rescue
ces missions sont effectuées
principalement au profit des personnels
militaires plus particulièrement des
pilotes
la recherche et le sauvetage en mer sont
des missions fréquemment effectuées au
cours d'entraînement l'intérêt est
équivalent pour le personnel de bord ou
pour le pilote qui doit supporter la
combinaison étanche
les pilotes peuvent au cours de ces
exercices utiliser l'ensemble de leurs
équipements de survie et de
signalisation dans un cadre sécurisé
pour des plongeurs sauveteurs ses
missions et entraînements ont lieu bien
entendu sur l'ensemble des territoires
d'outre-mer et sur le territoire
national
la base d'istres doté d'ateliers ultra
moderne assure l'entretien et la
maintenance courante de ces hélicos
grâce à un personnel hautement qualifié
qui livrent aux pilotes des hélicos à la
fiabilité incontestable
les mouches plus que toi
las illas est consacré
c'est mieux de livres 6,1 milliards
puma est super puma de l'armée de l'air
participent à des missions de la plus
haute importance selon l'état major
il s'agit de missions resco recherche et
sauvetage au combat
deux dispositifs à deux machines
s'introduisent en cas de besoin derrière
les lignes ennemies dans le but de
récupérer des pilotes qui se serait
injecté afin de les ramener dans leurs
forces ces missions très délicates sont
réalisées par des professionnels
parfaitement entraîné les commandos
parachutistes de l'air
basée à villacoublay
l'escadron 3,67 paris 6 dispose de trois
super puma as332 dont le volet
d'effectuer le transport sur des courts
moyenne distance les invités de l'état
major ou des membres du gouvernement eux
mêmes
ces missions peuvent avoir lieu sur
l'ensemble du territoire national mais
aussi en mer comme nous le montre cette
visite sur le porte avions charles de
gaulle
fenech et puma de l'armée de l'air sont
utilisés au quotidien dans l'ensemble
des missions de combat sauvetage
rapatriement sanitaire reconnaissance et
mise en place des forces au sol
l'ensemble des escadrons et les hommes
qui le composent sont présents partout
avec la même détermination et la même
efficacité
l'efficacité des machines est assurée
par les ateliers du cih véritable
académie des voilures tournantes sur la
bea sans les hélicoptères de tous types
font l'objet de visites approfondies
l'opération d'entretien et de réparation
extrêmement poussées afin de garantir
leurs aptitudes au combat pendant de
nombreuses années
le cougar et la future version du super
puma
développé par eurocopter au fuselage
courts ou longs il équipera l'armée de
l'air à partir de 2005 et pourra
recevoir divers armements il sera même
équipé d'une perche de ravitaillement en
vol
puissant et maniable ce nouvel
hélicoptère dispose d'un cockpit
entièrement modernisé d'une motorisation
toujours plus puissante avec régulation
numérique et d'un rotor à cinq pales son
aérodynamique autorise une vitesse de
rotation plus lente réduisant les
vibrations et le bruit le ses 725 est un
hélicoptère aux performances en hausse
avec plus de charge utile plus
d'autonomie
il ya un entretien simplifié
les pilotes dans l'accomplissement de
leurs missions sont exposés à des
risques nombreux
un pilote de s'éjecter de son aéronef et
s'est retrouvé au sol blessés ou choqués
dans la capacité de se déplacer après
avoir déclenché une balise le pilote à
temps le secours les hélicoptères
décollent très vite et se rendent sur
les lieux guidés par les contrôleurs
aériens
rapidement après seulement quelques
passes de reconnaissance l'infortuné
pilote ayant déclenché son feu de
détresse et localisés
les hélicos se pose pour déposer le
médecin qui se rend auprès du blessé
afin d'établir un premier diagnostic
le pilote est embarqué dans les micros à
côté d'un médecin et se dirige vers
l'hôpital le plus proche afin de
recevoir des soins appropriés à son cas
au cours d'un exercice en vol deux
pilotes sont amis à s'éjecter sur la
plage l'un d'eux apparemment indemne
cher son équipier blessés qui gît sur le
sable de batié
l'alerté donnée par les autres alphajet
de la patrouille qui volait avec eux
aussi tout un groupe de recherche se
constituent les deux pilotes a priori
qui sont éjectés et a priori il ya il
était percé en et revenez la delta 31 et
il ya les deux alphajet les deux autres
qui sont passés verticale a priori il
était en bonne fille ana qui dit j'ai
les bras qui les signent
les partis avec l'éjection de la machine
à machine dès lors que sa requête en
version sa terre en place droite
copilote
on a le sergent
prions visera en mer centrale rappelle
qu'on a
un briefing est organisée rapidement les
avec un maximum de renseignements et de
précision ce bris fait fondamental pour
éviter de disperser les efforts au cours
de la mission qui débloque médecin
équipage embarque au plus vite pour se
rendre sur zone
le pilote de chasse de boue agite son
fumigènes rouges pour aider les
sauveteurs dans leurs recherches
l'objectif étant repéré le puma se pose
afin que le médecin et les deux
plongeurs sauveteurs qui l'accompagnent
se rendent auprès des blessés
ceux ci reçoivent des soins d'urgence
pour prévenir toute aggravation de leur
cas avec d'infinies précautions et
spécialistes médicaux les entoure de
soins et de matériel de surveillance et
de contention les mettant à même de
supporter un ellis transport vers
l'hôpital le plus proche
l'hélicoptère qui s'est éloignée afin de
laisser les sauveteurs faire leur
travail dans de bonnes conditions se
pose à nouveau afin d'effectuer
l'embarquement des blessés les
sauveteurs plongeurs héliporté sont
tenus de maintenir leur forme et leur
condition physique à la perfection
ils ne savent jamais de quelle nature
sera la prochaine mission qui les auront
à accomplir ni combien de temps elle va
durer mais ils savent que tout le monde
compte sur eux partout dans le monde et
h 24
l'alerté donnée en début de matinée un
pilote s'est éjecté en mer il est
conscient et attendant son canot
pneumatique qui équipaient son siège
éjectable
immédiatement le laisse à 330 puma de le
h6 67 de la base aérienne 126 de
solenzara se porte au secours du
naufragé
l'hélicoptère atteint la zone de
recherches est à l'issue de quelques
passages au dessus des flots le pilote
est localisée celui ci disposait de
fumigènes rouges et de fluorescéine
colorante qui a laissé une belle trace à
la surface de la mer
les plongeurs se met à l'eau rejoignent
le pilote est sous le brouillard d'eau
créé par les pales du puma rester en vol
stationnaire il prépare le rescapé un
hélitreuillage qui lui sera salutaire
de retour à la base le pilote est
embarqué sur l'air de stationnement même
dans une ambulance qui le conduira à
l'hôpital
mission de la plus haute importance
l'art est ce qu de la base de cazaux a
une vocation interarmées les groupes de
récupération au sol
s'ils tiennent prêts à voler au secours
des éventuels pilotes aux équipages
ayant abandonné leur aéronef
la mission principale de l'escadron
réside dans la récupération de personnel
en perdition en zone hostile
oui
l'eau
après un briefing méticuleux
les pumas se rendre sur la zone de
récupération en empruntant un
cheminement tactique établie en fonction
de la menace
au cours du trajet l'un des hélicos
assure la conduite de la mission tandis
que l'autre se préoccupe de la
navigation et de la tactique
on
les pilotes étant repérer les hélicos
dépose les commandos soit en s'opposant
soit par descente par corde lisse les
hommes du grs identifie le pilote
cracher jauge son état de santé le
récupère à bord
sur le site les hélicos peuvent avoir un
rôle différent l'un d'eux assurant la
récupération tandis que l'autre le
couvre en utilisant son arme de sabor ou
en se posant si la situation l'exigé
parfois lorsque le terrain est accidenté
l'hélico dépose les hommes à plusieurs
kilomètres du pilote
dans ce cas les commandos auront à
s'infiltrer dans les lignes ennemies
pour rejoindre le pilote éjecté et le
ramener dans une zone où l'hélico pourra
le récupérer par pause ou à l'aide d'un
treuil
les opérateurs du centre de conduite des
opérations aériennes viennent de
détecter un écho non identifiés se
dirigeant à faible vitesse vers une zone
interdite sur l'ordre du centre de
conduite
deux hélicoptères fennec du 3,67 paris
six vont décoller pour tenter de ramener
l'avion suspect sur un itinéraire
autorisés ou de l'obliger à se poser
afin d'être mis entre les mains des
autorités
de toute façon on évite le secteur 30
degrés ou trente 30 degrés gauche ou
droit puisque
l'intercepter sera masqué donc on
favorisera un secteur 2 avec une
approche sur ces secteurs dont on
arrivera et le but c'est d'effectuer le
courbe du chien pour rester toujours
pour garder l'intercepter dans un angle
30° gauche donc là on le garde en visuel
et puis au fur et à mesure qu'on avance
on va le maintenir toujours gauche
toujours gauche jusqu'à l'acquisition
visuel tu m'as annonce acquisition jvn
et là c'est toi qui prendra lé bâton
c'est toi qui prendra les commandes la
première escadrille du paris 6 a été
désignée comme leader de la maza mesures
actives de sûreté aérienne et a dû en
définir les domaines d'emploi ont
tireurs d'élite des cp a effectué un
travail résultant d'une recherches très
poussées en matière de procédures et de
positionnement le calme avec lequel se
prépare les tireurs d'élite ne traduit
ni habitudes ni sûreté de soi mais tout
simplement un état de concentration
intense et cela même au cours d'un
exercice au sol avant même le décollage
les hommes qui ne savent pas ce qui les
attend près par la mission en répétant
déjà les gestes qu'ils seront amenés à
accomplir quand le moment de passer à
l'action sera venu
on
équipé de tous les moyens de vision
nocturne les fennecs de la maza protège
de jour comme de nuit
l'espace aérien principalement au dessus
de paris
des équipages identiques seront bientôt
en place à istres et sur d'autres bases
afin de garantir au mieux la paix dans
le ciel de france
lamy